hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel and if you don't know me i
worked in games media for eight years i
think
uh wrote a lot of reviews before moving
to game development which is what i do
now
and i've always found talking about
video game reviews and the conversation
surrounding them to be very interesting
um especially because there are a lot of
stuff that i feel like a lot of people
don't know until they kind of work in
that part of the video game media
industry uh so today i specifically
wanted to talk about what i think is
just a very interesting
case um
and just i don't know
touch on some things that i feel like i
don't see people discuss a lot so
i wanted to talk about elden ring
reviews um right now
it looks like actually the game is
getting uh review bombed in the user
scores um
it currently has more negative reviews
and user scores than positive reviews uh
but of course the
[Music]
critic reviews based on 45 critic
reviews right now is a 95 meta score a
lot of 10 out of 10 scores from a lot of
the biggest gaming websites um
and it is
one of the
highest rated games uh ever um i guess
it's dropped a little bit from the 97
that it seemed to be at for the first 24
hours but um
basically
i just think this is a very interesting
case and i've seen a lot of people say
like i don't think it deserves a 10 out
of 10 how has this happened and it was
almost impossible for elden ring i think
to ever not receive 10 out of 10 review
scores um
i personally would not have given it to
10 out of 10 i think that uh we are way
too forgiving with fromsoft regarding
their network issues
um i still have a really bad frame rate
drops i would say i have frame rate
drops every
10 seconds like very very frequently if
i'm writing around the open world
and i know that souls fans will get very
mad at me for for saying this or at
least some more hardcore ones i've been
a souls fan for a very long time
um
i think the
lack of direction regarding a lot of
items
is obtuse it's not like i think it
should be spelled out for people i think
that discovery is fun
but in some cases i just think it's um
a negative
for the game design however i love the
game and i think it does a lot of things
incredibly well
i'm a big fan regardless
i think it's one of the best games ever
made i just don't think it's a 10 out of
10 but i also never gave anything a 10
out of 10 in my entire uh career as a
game reviewer so maybe i'm not equipped
to do that
so in any case
eldon ring was always going to get tense
and i think it's because it exists in
this really particular
niche but not that niche because they do
sell well they are very popular games
in the industry where
only there are viewers that really like
from soft games
are likely to review a fromsoft game
that applies to everything so for
context when i worked at ign the way
that reviews worked was that you would
uh
get a spreadsheet like an excel
spreadsheet that was sent to all of the
reviewers are actually all of the
writers nobody at ign is actually a
full-time reviewer so just all of the
writers
and you would put your name next to
anything that you're interested in
sometimes there would be games listed in
there that i hadn't heard of so i would
go and google them be like yeah this
looks pretty cool and that's how i ended
up reviewing some more obscure games
sometimes just because i had looked them
up and was interested in them um
so you put your name next to the games
and there are always multiple people's
names i would say for like every first
party sony title
there were a lot of names um basically
anyone who's interested in reviewing it
for any reason they don't have to
specify why
we'll put their name there and then the
reviews editor the executive editor of
reviews who is currently dan stapleton
i believe the way dan did it was that he
would
reach out to
those people's individual managers
and see who had uh the best workload
when the code came in so say
someone might be out of town or wasn't
in the office that day they would miss
out
um
someone was already assigned to a big
feature or to cover an event which is
obviously a huge part of working in
games media's events coverage
and then it would just end up being a
matter of like okay well who hasn't
reviewed a game in the longest amount of
time
or
i don't know a million other things but
it gets it gets whittled down very
quickly just from the pool of people who
are interested to who's the most
available i would think is
most common uh especially because when
you work in games media you are always
busy so there
is probably most of the time only one
person who actually has the time
to review a game because it means all of
their other responsibilities have to
fall by the wayside
where
from soft games are concerned
because
they do have a different barrier to
entry than other games do
i think that the only people who will
submit to do them and thus almost by
default will review them every single
time if they work for a publication long
enough for multiple fromsoft games to
come out and we think the same people
would review it every time
because
of that barrier entry even casual
players say somebody who's played dark
souls but perhaps not played anything
else or played sekero but hasn't played
any of the dark souls or just played
bloodborne would probably not put their
names down to review eldering um again
in part because of that barrier
of entry
uh in part because reviewing something
that is difficult can be very
frustrating um because you have a time
limit so
it's something that a lot of people
probably don't want to take on and then
i think also in part because
the audiences for these games can be so
brutal
that
if you aren't a hardcore fan i think you
are likely to um
get a lot of flack
for
not having played every single fromsoft
game or knowing everything about them
inside out
so that means they are uniquely skewed
to only being reviewed
by
hardcore fans who are obviously
predisposed to give them
very high review scores and
the truth of the matter is that you
can't
make somebody who's not interested in
reviewing something review it because
that comes with its own bias so if you
were to say okay then i'm not gonna let
a hardcore fan review this so that we
get an opinion not from a hardcore fan
there are upsides and downsides to that
anyway uh it means that the people who
are hardcore fans are gonna hate the
review um people who are middling fans
who
may not have even looked for the review
because they're not hardcore fans um
might be served by it but uh
a lot of upsides and downsides to that
but you can't make somebody who doesn't
want to review something review
something
because they're going to go in negative
frustrated not wanting to do it um i did
occasionally review things i wasn't
super interested in but never something
that i like really didn't want to review
uh i was assigned
um
i did like a just dance or a dance
central or something one time and i did
it so that i
could
keep the switch for longer i didn't have
a switch on launch um
i basically couldn't afford it at the
time that it came out or i couldn't
justify the cost of it at the very least
san francisco was very expensive and i
was not making a lot of money um so i
did like a just answer at dance central
which i do not care about at all
just so that i could keep the switch
and keep using it for longer um i had
also done like skylanders i think two
skylanders games stuff that i like i'm
not particularly interested in but i was
like sure
i don't mind doing this it's also nice
sometimes to get a break from other work
and just play and record a game for a
whole week it can be nice to vary that
up but
if you're going to try to give somebody
who's not interested in fromsoft a
fromsoft game 2 review
i don't think that you are going to get
a review that would be reflective of
majority of the player base i think that
you're going to get somebody who is
annoyed from the jump is more likely to
get frustrated is more likely to feel
negatively about things so it skews in
the other direction and i mean again
truth is you just can't make somebody
review it if they don't have interest in
reviewing it um it just wouldn't it just
wouldn't work that way
i'd love to think that there are people
who are only slightly
you know casually interested in trump's
up games that have attempted to review
them
but i think it's pretty unlikely at
least from any of the major websites my
guess and in my experience
they probably have a fromsoft person
they have a person who
reviews and covers all of the fromsoft
stuff or all of the miyazaki stuff
um who is a go-to who everyone's gonna
be like well obviously this person is
going to do this obviously who else
would do this
and
there's an interesting thing that comes
from that where
there are certain other franchises that
i think get affected by this
in different ways that i
haven't
really thought about until i was
thinking about the fromsoft thing of
like how it was guaranteed to get tense
um
and and virtually all from games are
unless they stray from their formula
super dramatically because of the way
that these reviews are set up um and of
course all humans are biased goes
without saying i say it every time i
talk about reviews all humans are biased
we are incapable of objectivity you just
have to try to be objective or at least
try to explain why you feel a certain
way in a review but we aren't capable of
actual objectivity
so to talk about a completely different
franchise
if you think about
fifa or madden or any of the sports
games that get the frequent complaints
that are basically along the lines of
like
it's the same thing every year they
haven't changed anything
how did this reviewer give this a good
score give this an 8 give this a 7
whatever it's the same thing every year
copy paste
i've never reviewed any sports games for
the record
and this is mostly hypothetical but
i would think that similarly to people
who aren't going to volunteer to review
fromsoft games
unless they love them
the hardcore fans of a fifa or a madden
who feel the same way that you do
as a player who are also burnt out and
sick of things feeling the same
are unlikely
to want to review those games for a
similar reason
um
they're fans so they play in their spare
time outside of reviewing them of course
and i think it's probably pretty likely
that your fifa player who's played fifa
for 10 years and is sick of whatever
parts of fifa
are the same
isn't going to put their name down
because they're as sick of it as the
audiences thus meaning the reviews are
coming from people who maybe skipped a
year or maybe skipped two years and had
that break so they're coming in
a little bit fresher i think this is
entirely possible this happens for
madden as well um and of course this is
like a a thing that i don't even know
how i review websites sold there are
many issues with reviews i have like
some major issues with the way that
reviews function that i've mentioned
before but this is one that i just feel
like is like a human thing that i don't
know how you fix is
yeah if you're
a fifa or madam player and you're sick
of fifa or madden then you're not going
to opt to review fifa or madden
you just wouldn't want to do it you'd
say i'm sick of them they're the same
every year somebody else do this and
then that means that you get somebody
new in
who potentially isn't sick of those
things
which again
is a catch-22 that is
bad
for the audience who plays every year
because they don't get
a review that's reflective of exactly
what the last title looked like
but good for anybody who doesn't play it
every year religiously which has to be a
pretty significant portion of people and
probably people who would find reviews
the most useful because in my head
people who play fifa and madden
are already gonna buy fifa and madden
and don't necessarily care about reviews
um that of course doesn't apply to
anybody sorry apply to everybody
but what about a new player who's like i
want to learn about this new
fifa i just got into premier league
football let's learn about fifa maybe
i'll buy it if they read the review from
the person who is
annoyed at finding certain parts of the
franchise repetitive they're not going
to want to play it even though they may
not have those same gripes
but if they read the review from the
person who is a little bit fresher to
fifa it would align with their
perspective more closely
um
and i just thought that was a thing that
i was only just thinking about when
thinking about like okay if elden ring
is guaranteed to review well
what else is what else is guaranteed to
review a little bit better and
fifa and madden example is not a one to
one to that i was just heading down that
train of thought it's something that i
just thought was
worth noting it's probably the same with
um
uh 2k um
nba it's there they're probably a number
of games that are pretty similar i think
um
racing games in my experience at ign
were often reviewed by the same person
so they probably have
an unusual bias where
they play every single racing game and
thus are comparing every single racing
game because they review all of them
whereas
the
general consumer the person who's
reading a review does not play every
single racing game they play
two a year or they have one that they
really like so the review is skewed to
intentionally or not comparing the game
to every other racing game
where
the reader is
just trying to find
the one
racing game
um
basically paints a picture of how biased
reviews are again because we're humans
it's it's unavoidable we can't not be
biased i don't think that uh you should
ever expect reviews to be
uh devoid of bias there are there are
some biases that i think can get
problematic and shouldn't exist but
completely devoid of bias it ain't
happening it ain't possible
and um
yeah i mean the same obviously applies
for the user scores uh
the fact that there are more negative
user reviews on metacritic right now
than positive user reviews is absurd to
me
like
it's it's a strange part of the
conversation that we act like user
review scores aren't also extremely
biased because
of course they are you're also humans
with very strong opinions in one
direction or the other and i think my
selection my sorry my suggestion for
this
for the consumer for the person who is
playing games in his reading reviews and
is trying to get
um
the best review for what their specific
experience is because of course
it's impossible to write a review for
everybody's experience you have to write
it based on your own experience you
can't write it knowing how much or how
little somebody has played you can try
you don't know though um that's why i
don't like value discussions and reviews
people will say is this worth 60
you always have to ask i don't know
how much money do you have in your bank
account if you have a hundred dollars in
your bank account it's not worth 60
dollars
if you have 10 000 in your bank account
it's probably worth 60 dollars value's
subjective in itself it's so hard to
like
tell somebody what a value they should
assign 260 or 100 for a video game which
i just feel like it doesn't work that
way um
so my suggestion and the thing that i
think is best for
readers or consumers is to read multiple
reviews i do think that there is um
some potential help
in finding one or two particular
reviewers that you know that you usually
align with and that you know you have
similar gaming history too because that
is obviously gonna inform a lot of the
reviews
um but yeah also to re to read as many
perspectives as you can and
while it would be very nice for websites
to have an elder ring review from a
hardcore fan and an elden ring review
from a newbie and an elden ring review
from a middling fan um then i don't
doubt some of them will do that with
like their features or whatever
it's ultimately not cost effective
because like i said all of those people
all have jobs that aren't the review
that they have to be taken off for the
review so sometimes that means other
people have to take on my workload to
get everything done
um it's not feasible to have multiple
people reviewing games all the time i
think you would lose money um
and then people get laid off and then
there are no reviews so that doesn't
really help so
yeah i don't know i just kind of wanted
to talk about this because i thought it
was it was interesting um
probably not even going to edit this
video this is just me talking about
reviews
and biases and how they work and why i
think um fromsoft is in a really unique
spot regarding
review scores and there are other
franchises that i feel similarly about
call of duty is another one it's it is
um
probably always going to get very
similar
scores
because the audience or the people who
are interested in reviewing it
have very similar experiences and
backgrounds with first person shooters
or with call of duty itself it's just um
humans gonna human is effectively my
point
uh and i don't know i never think that
you should take reviews too seriously at
the end of the day
it is just somebody's opinion that is
that is it it is someone else's opinion
you can take it or leave it
that is up to you um
hope you enjoyed this video let me know
uh if you can think of any other games
you feel like i like inherently set up
to get like
pre-scripted review scores i think it's
an interesting one so yeah
i will see you guys next time bye